[Applause]
i'm gonna let you guys in on a little
secret
i love love i love love stories i
do and our series drew's love bug is all
about having honest conversations about
l-o-v-e and today we're diving into the
world of
dating apps i wanted to chat with three
women who can tell me what it's really
like
swiping for love and trust me i want to
know it all
first up there's gina from troy new york
she's been on dating apps for 12 years
and here's her go-to hack
deleting an app and re-downloading it to
get
fresh matches very smart
and next up is ashley from houston texas
she's been using apps for around four
years and she's been stood up
three times by her matches i
it's happened to me too i get it and
she's decided a trick that i'm really
excited about she's going nationwide to
find the right guy smart
last but not least abby from sacramento
she's been using apps for 2.5 years
and she's been more on more than 100
dates
not bad her mom is actually managing one
of her dating apps for her
cue my nightmare alright let's meet them
hi ladies hi drew
oh my gosh i'm so happy to meet you guys
so tell me fill me in
what's it like navigating these dating
apps i mean
i'm shocked by the amount of apps out
there let's see there's bumbler tinder
hinge dig which is a must love dogs app
and the list goes on and on
so tell me gina ashley and abby
gina let's start with you what app are
you currently on and using
so i have used them all pretty much
everyone that you've named but right now
i use
tinder a lot and i found that i thought
at first it was really a lot about
hooking up but
i think it's just totally what you make
it and i use that at the most because i
find i talk to the most
people on that app i can talk to them
quickly we can meet up quickly and
you know you know it all just happens so
fast and it's just easier i've talked to
most people through that app
there's a geographical component to
tinder too right like it pings if you're
near each other yes it'll tell you if
you're x amount of miles away from
someone whether it's 60 miles two miles
so
it definitely knows your proximity with
other people i mean that is just so
future hello okay ashley
what apps are you on um well like gina i
have tried all of them
but currently i'm on match.com eharmony
and tinder
i've actually paid for both eharmony
and match.com with hopes to weed out and
like get the good guys
um i'm using tinder as well and i've
picked up
i picked that one back up so i'm using
it a lot more but i'm finding still that
it's a lot of hookups but like gina
again i hear all these great stories so
maybe i'll have some luck on tinder one
day
okay abby what app are you on
um i'm currently on
that's the one i've been using the most
i feel like it's a little bit of a
step up from a tinder where guys have to
put in some more information
and it's like they have to at least seem
like they're putting in an effort
so that's the one i've been using but
i've also been
on j date my grandma actually signed me
up for jdate
my dad signed me up for meet mindful
and now my mom signed me up for coffee
meets bagels
and she um she's managing the app for me
how is the coffee meets bagels i read
about that app and i was intrigued
i think it's a lot more intensive like
you have to answer a lot more questions
and
i think it's attracting guys who are a
little bit more
serious about dating because i've gone
on some dates with guys she set me up
with
and they do feel like they're a little
bit more like
reliable calling you know making plans
to see you and all that kind of stuff so
so you and your mom have a healthy
relationship
i would um i would say we have a
relationship
where she wants me to find someone
even more than i do wait do you want to
meet someone or is this all about your
mom
i really do want to meet someone but it
gets so overwhelming
on these apps and it's like you know
similar to what the other girl said like
i'll download it and i'll be on it for a
while and then i'll
then i get burnt out because you match
with you know a thousand guys
and then a hundred talk to you and then
you go on dates with
three of them and then you don't like
any of them well we're going to talk to
a dating expert who met her
husband on an app as well
so not only is she an expert in her
field but
she's an expert in this subject awesome
but first will you ladies be my
dictionary
and explain to me these terms these
words that occur
in the dating app world all right first
one
kitten fishing kitten fishing um
it's definitely when guys give you a
fake version of themselves like it's
actually them so it's not a full catfish
but where they will show maybe where
they look a lot hotter than what they
really look like or like they'll show
themselves really in shape but they have
like a
super dad bod you know like that
look take the super dad bot if they're
nice to you every day
all right abby submarining
submarining is when guys show their
interests
and then disappear kind of like they're
ghosting and then they pop back up
out of nowhere and that's happened to me
recently
[Music]
interesting okay uh gina flexting
oh yeah flexing definitely happens all
the time when someone is
bragging way too much about themselves
through the dating apps and through
texting before you ever
meet them in person okay and we're going
to coin
something here today are you ready for
it we all came up with it together i'm
super excited
lead footing when a when a guy goes from
zero to 60
out of nowhere oh yeah that happens
all right tell them stop lead footing